coluche vous allez demander à 100 da
nombreuses années devenir aujourd'hui y
en a beaucoup qui sont pas venus
je dois dire qu'il y avait un policier
qui m'avait dit que une fois l'amitié de
venir jusqu'ici puis finalement dernier
moment il a donné des trucs à faire avec
sa femme il voulait aller dans un an je
sais pas quoi vous aviez demandé
effectivement la présence d'un
représentant des syndicats de policiers
d'un policier on m'avait dit que j'en
avais un du syndicat qui voulaient bien
venir
alors moi je m'étais intéressé un homme
du syndicat de la police parce
qu'appartenant la police à des
revendications à faire je me trouve en
face d'un homme qui m'intéresse parce
que moi aussi j'en ai à faire des
revendications justement à propos de la
police briller et donc fallu un terrain
discussions - mais c'est à dire que les
marocains discussions que j'ai c'est une
liste voilier que ce que vous montrez et
ça c'est un mort et un blessé par jour
par la police depuis le 1er janvier
donc effectivement ça m'intéresse voyez
le 7 janvier à mort le 13 janvier deux
morts un blessé le 9 janvier encore un
tabac c'est selon se traînera vous
remarqué que quand même rigolé le dise
un flic arrêté pour viol le 13 un mort
jeudi mais c'est ric hochet contumace
vous savez ceux qui sont arrêtés enfin
ne prennent pas tous non plus des
gentils garçons là ils étaient tous
installés par cet art mais aussi non il
était probablement la place du syndicat
de policiers il est il a pas voulu
mais ce que je veux dire c'est qu'ils
ont effectivement la police a pas un
rôle facile et moi je suis pas contre la
police en général 1
ce qu'il faudrait c'est qu'ils
s'arrangent quand même pour qu'à la fin
de l'année y ait moins de morts du côté
des assassins du côté de la police ça me
paraît indispensable que l' équilibre
reste entier voyez vous pouvez pas
mettre sur la balance disons un policier
qui fait son travail ou son son devoir
puisque c'est le terme qui fait son
devoir tire toujours sur un arabe en
tombant derrière dans le dos
expliquez-moi expliquez moi ce que les
policiers foot dans le dos des arabes
avec un revolver à la main et à chaque
fois ils tombent
racontez moi pourquoi du manneken raison
moi je suis d'accord le parme c'est
qu'il ya pas de raison que ça le
problème
faye en a une en fait oui c'est que les
policiers se croit extrêmement couvert
moi je suis pour le principe rhin de la
police je suis pas une personne peut
être contre ça serait ridicule de dire
qu'il faudrait qu'il y ait pas de police
je crois mais je pense que les policiers
devraient pas devrait d'abord être mieux
recruter parce que vraiment il
moi je suis allé dans un commissariat et
encore pas longtemps j'ai passé quelques
temps volontairement ou pas pas
exactement pas exactement je ne fais
plus d' enquête depuis un moment mais
comme il sait rien maintenant sérieux
quand fond c'est à dire que quand ils
ramassent que le chili vient
commissariat au moins va s'marrer est en
fait comme j'ai fait pas rire et moi
lâche assez vite et quand les gens
n'auraient plus si si bien sûr monsieur
sisi je me suis fait arrêter en
mobylette ya pas longtemps que j'avais
pas mes papiers devaient emballer
ils voulaient pas croire c'est moi que
je suis bon alors ça ça fait rien je
m'en fous une façon moi j'ai du temps à
perdre
je suis plus riche que lui alors je m'en
tamponne mais est ce que je veux dire
c'est que c'est vraiment un climat
d'abord ils pourraient les repeindre à
mon avis les commissaires allaient là il
pour être poli avec les gens qui
viennent parce que c'est un service
public c'est nous qui payons ils
pourraient ils pourraient se laver pour
la plupart très sain ou généralisée très
très simple et vous généralement élevés
qui passent leur vie en mobylette dans
paris sont crado quand ils ont pris
trois fois la flotte faut dire qu'ils
soient habillés un petit peu cheap aussi
peut-être
moi je les aurai j'en ai vu un petit
drap les plus coquets enfin bref c'est
un jour d'avoir vraiment l'impression
d'être attaqué par une bande de brigands
quand on va aux familles salle vraiment
annoncé faveur le représentant du
syndicat cela passerait par un policier
un carrefour un accident élevé bon vin
cadre et le flic est descendu il disait
sa femme appelle les collègues et tous
et ce mec là se croient protégés parce
que simplement il est policier
et ça je crois qu'il faut que ça cesse
bon on n'a pas pu rejoindre la cia nous
il ya moyen du représentant la police
vers ceux où la police
[Musique]